une finale et puis 120 face aux milanais
de monza pas de miracle pour le tbb une
défaite sans bavure 3 sets à 0 comme à
l'aller la cuc cv échoppes une fois de
plus aux tourangeaux qui n'a pourtant
pas démérité
poussé par son public ambiance hier soir
avec tristan weekly
les choeurs sont lourds l'appel est
grande pour les joueurs du tours volley
ball au moment de la remise des
récompenses
par oui c'est la déception salafin à
notre vouloir elle était là mais on
apparaît aussi gagné les points qui aura
besoin sur ton premier set une déception
à la hauteur des espoirs du public
tourangeau en ce début de match la salle
est comble et supporters fanfaronne
après le sacre de 2017 il rêve déjà d'un
second titre de champion d'europe
narbonne l'a fait hier soir donc il n'y
a pas de raison qu'on passe pas pareil
malgré le match aller on pense que
vraiment il ya possibilité de faire de
la zac grenon durant le premier set la
salle grenon se transforme en chaudron
elle tient sa réputation de meilleur
public de france les supporters poussent
leur équipe le score est serré mais
c'est mon gars qui douche les espoirs
avec leur deuxième balle de set
à partir de là le match échappe aux
tourangeaux les italiens font le forcing
durant la deuxième manche il s'impose 25
à 18 et décroche par la même occasion le
titre de champion d'europe
[Musique]
troisième et dernier set les joueurs du
tvb se rendent à l'évidence il n'y a
plus rien à gagner résultat le ced fils
sous les yeux peiné des supporters on
s'attendait quand même car anvers
c'est dommage on prend deux c'est comme
ça on a résumé de quoi mais c'est parce
qu'on perd
2,38 25 cents joueurs sur les canaux
sétois malgré la défaite marcello franco
viac l'entraîneur du tvb se veut
optimiste
il salue le parcours des tourangeaux je
veux aussi parler d'une réussite dans
cette coupe c -b qui nous a fait croiser
des gros calibres de championnat
européen en italie au même à bologne et
c'est république tchèque il faut être
fier de tout ce qu'elle a fait dans
cette coupe cv après cet échec redouté
l'équipe du tvb veut tourner la page au
plus vite les tourangeaux se concentre
déjà sur la prochaine coupe de france et
sur les playoffs du championnat de
france